Let's go next to Adrian from San Francisco,
California.
Hello.
Hello, David, can you hear me?
I can't, and you are you're not calling in
from San Francisco, Argentina.
Right, or San Francisco, California.
I didn't even know there was one in Argentina.
Many people don't.
Today, many people don't.
David, I want to ask you about what are your
thoughts on having U.S. troops in the Middle
East seeing there have been a recent delay
in removing troops from Afghanistan?
I'm asking because there's one hypothesis
where, you know, troops are necessary to stabilize
the area and prevent insurgencies.
But I'm really curious to see if you think
we even have an obligation in the first place
seeing the cost of American lives and capital.
Yeah.
So we've been talking about this really for
almost two full decades.
That that's the right.
I mean, the question fundamentally is that
of responsibility.
If we cause a problem in the
Middle East, how
long do we have a responsibility to stay for
so-called peacekeeping purposes and stabilization
purposes?
I have no clue.
I don't know what the answer is.
And, you know, we're we're in some of these
countries because of decisions made multiple
presidents ago by George W. Bush does.
But where does Joe Biden's responsibility
go for the destabilization that George W.
Bush to George Bush's decisions brought to
the Middle East?
I do not know what the answer is.
I think that at a certain point you can make
the case that if you say ahead of time to
the world community and to everyone involved.
We understand our role in creating the situation
that was many presidents ago and much foreign
policy ago, we are announcing that every troop
will be gone by X date.
Let's work together to figure out how to make
that a reality reality.
But the U.S. is getting out, period.
And then you figure out what to do.
I would think that that is that is at some
point has to be morally acceptable.
But your question of if you broke it, how
long do you have a responsibility to continue
fixing it is a good one.
And I don't know what the answer is.
You know, David, you make a really interesting
parallel to reparations, the case for reparations
by attorney HESI Coates, because it's the
same philosophical question of if we broke
something in this case, the horrible institution
of chattel slavery right now, how long does
it have to take?
And so we have to, you know, morally have
the obligation, a responsibility to.
Well, I think that one is a little different
and more complicated for for a few reasons.
One is that there's a question as to whether
if you just throw money at individuals
on the
basis that they are still affected by the
way the system used to work, you're arguably
ignoring elements of the system today that
still don't actually work correctly.
And and some folks believe that the first
step has to be to actually reform institutions
rather than than financial reparation.
I mean, this is a bigger topic.
It's a different topic than the one maybe
you're bringing up.
But I think that it's it's even more complicated,
arguably.
Yeah, it certainly is.
Hey, David, I'm a first time brand new listener
to your show, so keep it up.
All right.
Thank you so much.
Appreciate the call.
Very important.
Good substantive questions.
Love it